ridgewood new jersey an affluent suburb
well known for the sheer volume of
restaurants
smack in the middle of this pleasant
town is a five-year-old restaurant run
by a former manhattan star chef
paul bazzini i'm a very good chef we got
a full dining room drop another pan for
four more here we go i've always been in
the industry and worked my way up and
became an executive chef and worked in
many places in manhattan that had a lot
of notoriety i love you
love you too paula's been recognized
many times throughout his career he has
been written up in several magazines
with some very positive reviews and i
absolutely thought the restaurant was
going to be a success
but paul never anticipated the
transition from star chef to owner would
be so difficult i don't have any focus
these days i wake up in the morning and
i say what direction should i go in
today should i cook should i shop should
i work in the front of the house should
i work on marketing should i pay bills
and it's like overwhelming killing me i
think the pressure of owning the
restaurant has definitely beat him down
and his passion for food is not burning
as brightly as it once was clearly
what's going on with me in the kitchen
is suffering
here's your salad what salads what table
i'm confused i'm confused yeah new york
shift new york trip okay you're right i
am distracted i am frustrated i'm angry
always somebody always somebody always
somebody and then i'm frustrated with
the food and i'm slamming place down
because the plate doesn't look the way
that i want it to look it's messy but
let's just go with it okay the result
was burnt i don't know is it supposed to
be spicy a lot of complaints
yeah so i heard i don't feel like me i
feel like somebody else i feel like
me looking at somebody else
everyone knows that he's just not good
about criticism this needs to be heated
up these are perfect okay he gets pissed
off and he yells i don't have all the
tickets memorized why well that's why
you have a ticket yeah okay do you think
if you had a lot of money you wouldn't
be so goddamn moody
i support the restaurant financially
certainly if i didn't do that we would
have been bankrupt years ago there's no
magic atm machine like in the backyard
like a magic money tree that i can just
go pick money from there are no college
funds for our children every day i'm
scared that we're not going to be able
to pay the bills we need help we need
direction we need advice my resume and
all my accolades don't mean a hill of
beans if i can't make it work here his
passion for cooking
defines him and i feel like it's lost to
him right now he needs to get it back
[Music]
there are over 60 restaurants within
four blocks inside this beautiful town
now after seeing a few of them my mouth
is watering i can't wait for lunch
right buzzinis innovative american
cuisine
[Music]
what
[Music]
no
am i too late
buzzine is hours monday to thursday 5
till 9 30. [ __ ]
no lunch
that's ridiculous i pull gordon here
where i call me
[Music]
unbelievable
[Music]
hello
hi my speak to chef ramsay please is
that paul hi this is paul bizzini how
are you sorry i missed you i didn't
realize you're close for lunch uh yes
sir we're closed for lunch okay i'm on
my way
[Music]
i'm starving
how are you hi welcome to business chef
ramsay pleasure to meet you gordon
gordon paul pleasure to meet you nice to
see you too thank you wow this is my
nude isn't it it's challenging
my goodness me is this it yes sir
wow
it's like being inside a doll's house
it's uh some decor challenges here well
you're here yes sir finally i'm here
okay um
uh clearly there's nothing else going on
uh lunch-wise why don't you cook me
something okay yeah don't show me the
menu you decide okay yeah yeah
i have to just you know focus on like
the food will it be to his taste will it
be to his opinion
who knows
this place makes me feel nervous it's
small it's cramped and
i wanted the clothes for lunch yes so
narrow look at this place from one table
to the next
huh
[Music]
god they cry me
[Music]
oh [ __ ] nice depressing
[Music]
entree comes with sound effects
maybe he'll blow me away with a food
because the atmosphere
my god it's depressing
[Music]
i'm thinking that i want to send out
just a few light dishes to him something
hot something cold something grilled
something sauteed just a full rounded
experience hey paul i'm here to help hey
how's it going you got it good i think
chef ramsay's gonna have a lot of things
to say to paul about how to change
things and i don't think paul's gonna
take it well
the gentleman said he was very hungry so
fair enough i think paul has his own
ideas that what he's doing is just right
it doesn't need to be changed and uh i
think some of those things do need to be
changed here we go that is the
fettuccine mm-hmm basil arugula pesto
lower cotton salad on top what and then
behind that here is a chicken pie yard
those are milanese pounded breaded
excellent uh so i didn't catch your name
my name's alex alex charmed good to see
you so much pleasure i'll be back in a
moment thank you guys
[Music]
cold
bland
really bland
okay
look at this thing
it's like a [ __ ] elephant's
[Music]
that's foot normal for a chicken to be
so [ __ ] hard
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's the mess
thank you alex absolutely um i'd
appreciate if the chef could actually
taste that okay because it is bland
beyond bland okay um why is that so dry
i wish i had a good answer for that
question chicken should be moist well
i'll move straight to the next course
fettuccine bland
chicken why is it so dry that's [ __ ]
i want to go home
paul certainly doesn't like it when
people criticize his food but you know i
think he actually reacted to chef
ramsay's criticisms the same way he
reacts to a lot of the guest's
criticisms like maybe it's not
necessarily that important because he's
right
hello hello how are you very well i'm
leslie bussini
nice
it means a lot to us that you're here i
want to get emotional but thank you i'm
very happy to be here and uh can i give
you a hug
[Music]
feel better
here's someone who has the ability to
help us and um he's going to you know
that's a miracle
okay great well i'm going to finish my
uh lunch yes absolutely thank you thank
you thank you hi hello lovely thank you
here we are okay that is our mushroom
risotto mm-hmm
thank you okay
is that normal
[Music]
amazing buzziness risotto
well it's extraordinary no it doesn't
even move well maybe that looked better
up there
yeah
it fits the colors
[Music]
what a mess
and absolutely disgusting
so
you don't look too impressed i just take
some mush
thank you oh yeah my pleasure i'll bring
you some tilapia next
now he doesn't like that he doesn't like
it too mushy there is a classic you know
way to do it but some people around here
just don't like it that way you know my
ego's not here to hear that gordon
ramsay loved the dishes or didn't like
the dishes i'm not concerned about that
i'm concerned about what i do or how
what the product that i put out it's all
yours alex all right here we go
almond crusted tilapia
jasmine rice with some pepper hopefully
you enjoy it
wow
[Music]
i love the jasmine rice he has to like
the jasmine rice
hmm
just so bland honestly i mean it's just
greasy bland and
you cut into the fish and it just mush
how is the tilapia coming along we
making some forward progress here yeah
no you know what i'm uh
i'm still hungry uh do you have
something in mind
any desserts
certainly sharon our dessert chef makes
everything good i got a carrot cake oh
wow should be a new york cheesecake you
know a little slice of cheesecake and
the carrot cake done please
yes cheesecake carrot cake tilapia no go
fish was bland watery fish was bland
again we're kind of like we have an
older clientele here they like not to
assertive things
right how could i think that paul did a
good job you know if he did a good job
chef ramsay would have said the food was
great you know he didn't say that so
paul didn't do a good job start right
here with a carrot cake wow all homemade
yes absolutely thank you
hi
gordon's eating your carrot cake right
now as we speak
[Music]
oh
hi faye the last thing that people eat
is dessert and if the dessert sucks
that's
bad
[Music]
hey
bloody
do you scare me look around the corner
like that
sharon
first of all that is delicious awesome
whose recipe is that mine can i have it
no for a price everything right yeah i'm
glad you said that that's made with
passion as much as you have you make
love to that carrot cake don't you well
i'm getting divorced so it's the cake
i'll go for the cake
hope he likes it shark's gonna be
devastated if he hates it i hate it
i'm so glad you liked it honestly i felt
like as a [ __ ] waking a funeral and
all of a sudden the carrot cakes arrive
and roof and back up there i love you
although dessert left chef ramsay with a
good taste in his mouth
it still doesn't erase the bad taste of
the rest of the meal let's talk about
the food dessert let's go backwards okay
yeah that was delicious good great enjoy
it really good
great way to finish clearly but i
certainly didn't start off like that
i said to you show me your best give it
to me big time the risotto was
embarrassing
paul it tasted the way it looked damn is
that normal
bland
mushy and it looked atrocious
honestly it was [ __ ] disgusting
the chicken
how many days were you baking that for
seriously i mean you may laugh but it's
not funny honestly i thought i'd lost my
tooth it was so crunchy on the outside
dry in the middle it wasn't intended to
be dry or to be overcooked uh you sent
it out i know that that's the way you
normally cook it over done certainly
don't think that i cook food over time
okay risotto overcooked chicken
overcooked you certainly did for me
okay i i need to get some fresh air i'm
gonna come back later i'm here tonight
show it to me okay hopefully this time
with a little bit more effort okay
did you think that he was gonna like it
[Music]
it angers me that paul has given up
because
i haven't given up you're like
i want the nightmare to be over
[Music]
this former manhattan star chef failed
to impress chef ramsay at lunch now it's
time for chef ramsay to see how paul
handles the customers of ridgewood new
jersey in a dinner service all right
guys we got to get ready i hope paul
could get his [ __ ] together the food is
there the capability is there you just
have to do it it's like you have to [ __ ]
our cut off the pot
hello good evening can i take your wine
there you go you can enjoy and this is
ow ow good to see you you're a sous chef
right yes
this kitchen's like a [ __ ] shoe box
in here yeah i know holy crap i think
chef ramsay doesn't realize that i
worked with a lot of very well-known
chefs it's not intimidating i have the
talent the desire and i definitely can
do the job crab cakes across the board
so for this result
you smell good
i smell good i have to sharon are you
hitting on me no i like the aftershave
it smells nice oh maybe just brush your
eyes halfway no i'm not
gordon is adorable and of course he's
not quite the butt
i'm sorry
order in the crab cakes are ready okay
thank you
how come they cooked already
they're pre-seared
[Music]
you sarah crab cake no we appreciate the
crab cake and then it goes into the oven
now hold on a minute why wouldn't you do
that to order
for it to expedite it out a little bit
faster we're sure that it'll take longer
to get yes hotter one's already cooked
yes
is it new or does that not make sense it
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
[Music]
here is your crab cake sir may i get you
any fresh pepper on that oh no thank you
no
how strange how are they doing this is a
bucket of crab cakes
that just go into the oven to be
reheated but they were sit off like
yesterday
did you know they were done the day
before of course not i thought
everything was fresh everything
i feel like paul is losing his artistry
and that he doesn't care it's not
affecting him it not only pains me it it
angers me quite frankly i mean that's
just not okay
it's all burned on the side all i can
taste is the food it's burned is it
really yeah
is everything okay with your pancakes
i need another crab cake on the fly what
do they say i was burnt burn yeah
there's two more we're about to go out
please tell me i'm not gonna serve them
no i'm not sure we had issues with the
crab cakes tonight it's not the right
way to do it it should be done a
different way and i know how to do it a
different way but that's not how it was
done that is not it's [ __ ] disgusting
yes do something about it please pull
yourself he's a garbage this is not a
reflection of the way that i want things
to be okay
so how are we doing back there right
i'll go check for you
it's an hour into dinner service and
very little food has left the kitchen
in order to get an accurate picture of
the slow down that's not ready there's
no potatoes on it honey okay chef ramsay
times how long cooked food sits at the
pass
[Music]
i just think i eat
sitting here waiting for our food okay
four minutes sat there steak
paul that's still there yes i'm working
on everything everything is working hey
let me bring some food out there
yeah but does she have her
paul is communicating but most of his
communication is that he can't handle it
and it's going too fast
you're going to have to leave though
yeah no all joking about this yeah at a
good point it is a little bit like a
little yeah
okay these people are gonna leave if i
don't get this one out he decides how
fast things come out i don't know why it
takes so long i just know what takes so
long
okay table 32 can now go thank you i
love them finally yes
and now after a long wait those potatoes
look a little overdone the customers
aren't satisfied
okay no problem i'll send that back for
you okay thank you
paul what's wrong hi it's cold oh come
on
i've certainly become annoyed with
clients and i feel like you know people
that want to give you criticism they
just don't know like what you're going
through and if they just knew like a
little bit of what you were going
through they might be a little bit more
compassionate but it's not a
compassionate business
is this going paul i'm just worried
about food coming back cold and this is
sat here i was told that the salads
would be ready i'm waiting for the
salads
take half of that salad off me are you
building a [ __ ] christmas tree no
half the plates don't look the way they
should when i don't do them well when i
put them just take half of the salad off
please follow my direction so i'm gonna
help you okay i'm not here to hurt you
i'm here to help you contrary to what
everybody says i do know a few [ __ ]
things
easy to sum up paul's moods if he were a
woman he would have pms 24 7. okay
so let me demo a chicken milanese for
the 400 [ __ ] time which is nothing
more than chicken and salad and my 12
year old can [ __ ] do it yeah listen
don't push it paul when i don't put it
high enough you yell at me that it's not
freaking high enough why do you have to
make it so difficult for it why can't we
why can't
why can't we just finish this chicken
milanese and make this particular
chicken milanese a right one not talking
about yesterday not time or next month
but what's with the [ __ ] sarcasm
you don't want [ __ ] well i'm not
saying you changed a year what the [ __ ]
you want from me changing it right well
you told me the first [ __ ] time
we already have to make it so difficult
why can't we the battle to get food out
tonight has resulted in a war in the
kitchen well what's with the [ __ ]
sarcasm what the [ __ ] you want from me
and the impact is being felt in the
dining room get my food now
who's waiting one
34 has been waiting for like an hour i
know this big tail were behind me what
are they waiting on who's table was that
julie's how long are we waiting on trays
over an hour yeah it's over an hour this
is not normally surely no no tonight is
the worst dinner service that i have
ever seen i mean i have never
experienced anything like this in my
life
okay there paul yes sir i don't know
what's happened but the level of
frustration out there
is intense so
stop
we can't continue like this
stop it
will you apologize the tables please
rebecca
what a freaking disaster bad i know it
was a terrible night we had people not
get food when tickets were here we
failed tonight it's my responsibility
sorry my friends the kitchen has been
shut down
i'm so sorry i've never had to do this
before
i never saw anything like that my weight
i understand that do you think that i
like this you think that i want it to be
like this i don't but
but what i'm one person with two hands
well you don't please don't start with
excuses that's not gonna help paul had a
horrible night a hundred percent off his
game and i think gave up before he even
got started but people hated the food
well that's not what we got back here
i'm very angry saying that someone liked
something 50 people didn't like it open
your eyes i have nothing else to say to
you
equally as miserable as tonight's dinner
service was paul's attitude and chef
ramsay wants to know why
tonight showed me that you hated cooking
i cannot ignite that little button i
need to see it from you jeff i feel
awful i this is not the way that i want
to work or the way that i know that i
can work why are you doing it to
yourself i i
why
you've got to give me the answer because
i can't start helping until you tell me
but i mean no one's asking you to rant
and rape i'm just asking to have some
fire
it's not normal for a guy that's been
cooking for 20 years plus to stand there
with no feel or passion and send [ __ ]
like that as if it's just going over
your head
whether you like or not
you have given up
your whole family is on the line here do
you know how hard it is to look at my
kids when i go home at night
[Music]
for my wife
[Music]
it's not easy
okay
it's supposed to be easy i don't care if
it's not easy i just want it to be
better
but don't stop trying
[Music]
think i'm happy
i'm miserable i don't want to get out of
bed in the morning i want to stay in bed
[Music]
okay listen i'm committed to helping you
and i'm not leaving this place until
it's set we are going to work at this
together at turning this around tomorrow
i want you at your best
yes yes get some sleep
thank you good night
[Music]
after an emotionally draining night chef
ramsay has a task in mind to help ignite
paul's passion in the kitchen
good morning hello um new day
new attitude
new start
so
last night it took us an hour
on average to get appetizers out so
here's what we're doing today i want you
to get used to the time pressure see i'm
saying like sort of you know
kickstarting the [ __ ] car again you
know a new battery in it
you've got 15 minutes yeah from now to
cook me
a stunning pasta dish off you go
try to kill me you can do it 15 minutes
in order for paul to impress chef ramsay
this chef is making fresh pasta for the
first time in five years i just want to
be able to do what i know how to do it
just you know just cook from the heart
and uh get back to raising the bar for
myself what are you gonna make i'm just
getting a lady to land that's all yeah
14 minutes the cloth is ticking and it's
just you know like everything around me
was just turned off like i wasn't
hearing or seeing or feeling or worrying
it was just you know i was living in the
moment
[Music]
10 minutes babe he's sitting he's ready
he's waiting to be served
you could totally totally wow him right
now please i was watching everything
that he did and i was definitely afraid
that chef ramsay wasn't going to like it
and and what that would mean can we
carry it out i'll carry it out you sure
you want to do that yes all right
hey here we go chef thank you you're
welcome we have a capolini pasta with a
chunky pontodeska sauce and some rock
shrimp lovely well i used to be a good
chef i think i'm still a good chef i
would just want him to be able to
recognize that there was a passion that
went into making it
[Music]
chef ramsay has put paul's passion for
cooking to the test we have a capolini
pasta with a pontenesca sauce lovely now
it's time to find out if he passed
i would hope that chef ramsay would
recognize that you know some love went
into making this dish will it be to his
taste
[Music]
who
knows
that's nice
capillini cooked perfectly thank you it
just felt good to just have a really
positive comment i'm chef ramsay i
really needed that lift what does pasta
mean to you to me it's like bread at
staff of life pasta can be anything you
can go through all different flavors
textures proteins colors you can have
dried pasta fresh pasta it's a blank
canvas it's no it's it's just something
for the artist to paint you're sounding
more exciting in the last two minutes
talking about pasta than you have done
since i've met you it was the old paul
he was excited he was energized it was
the man that i married and it's really
weird isn't it it takes something like a
pasta dish to sort of ignite how you
feel about it absolutely
today at this moment i know that like
the healing process has begun
after a small glimmer of hope this
morning chef ramsay wants to try an
experiment time for some sophisticated
marketing he wants to take advantage of
the ridgewood foot traffic and test
paul's speed in the kitchen how are you
so for the first time in four years
bizzini's is open for lunch having lunch
today fabulous lunch menu around the
corner business 15 soup salad and the
most amazing pasta wonderful thank you
so much thank you
now chef ramsay only has one thing left
to do
tell the owners so here's what we're
doing today we're going to serve
the most amazing two-course lunch
that's right this is not a formal
long-winded three-hour ordeal this is a
really nice easy
quick vibrant lunch i'm nervous but you
know this is what we're gonna do today
fantastic you know great you know
terrific you and i in the kitchen great
i'm your sous chef okay fantastic i'm
your [ __ ]
okay
ladies you've both got great
personalities so both you're running the
front of house
i don't know anything about the front of
the house i don't care about the front
of the house i just want to do my job
great service great food in and out
[Music]
hello welcome
uh follow me please chef ramsay is
hoping today's lunch will show paul and
leslie the opportunity they are not
taking advantage of don't have the pasta
special the fantina pasta and the power
of serving fresh pasta soup three
panzanella two okay good let's go
[Music]
two soups are going in the window chef
to go up with two salads salad's 30
seconds paul very good thank you don't
forget speed today yes yeah quarter in
one soup two orcate two pans and ella
three vegetable oreo can't say three
regular one candy very good
waitressing it's totally not my thing
i'll be right with you folks your girl's
okay we're just waiting on our wine
oh
um garlic oh my pen's not riding i'm
sorry sharon and i are not servers we
did the best that we could is everything
okay
oh yes i'm sorry but we forgot that you
need a spoon to eat soup where's the
spoon why are you asking me oh
god help me
oops i'm sorry service thank you
that looks great enjoy it
next time today is what two hour chat
days one vegetarian orange day it was
great working with gordon tate you know
we worked together we jumped around it
was good it was like a good two-man you
know vibe it felt good you know it felt
real good with chef ramsay and paul
working together you got four vegetarian
i got five normal yeah vegetarian on the
way excellent beautifully cooked fresh
pasta is flying out of the kitchen thank
you very much enjoy it there you go
my gosh this is so good that is like the
best possible like friendly stuff your
mom makes and you're in and out in no
time mm-hmm how is it very good good
good excellent good i'm glad the kitchen
did everything right today that's it the
board is cleared yeah yeah i don't have
any tickets anyone need food no food i
absolutely think lunch should be an
everyday thing at bizzini i think that
uh today probably proved that to paul
it was a great lunch service it was
really good it was profitable and we you
know we made money and customers were
happy and it was quick and it was easy
feel good
[Music]
inspired by paul's performance during
lunch and his fresh pasta chef ramsay
and his teamwork overnight to renovate
the restaurant
[Music]
morning hey everybody
welcome to the new casino
[Laughter]
wow look at it new trellising new sign
it looks inviting it's gorgeous the
neighborhood with 60 restaurants you
have to stand out it looks spectacular
awesome the trellis just looks beautiful
ready to go inside yes let's go i have
ants in my pants
oh
look at this
the tables are gorgeous i love these
chocolates look at that that's so nice
gone is a lemon pound cake on the walls
new slick italian bonkers isn't that
lovely it's just modern it looks great
the color is contemporary look at the
napkins fresh pasta made daily welcome
to brazilian this is freaking awesome
the dining room is beautiful
i never thought in a million years this
could happen and um
we are so grateful thank you again
oh good morning i'm glad you're happy
the restaurant renovation was drastic
but the biggest change to bizzini's is
the menu chef ramsay has taken the old
risotto the disgusting chicken and the
bland tilapia and replaced them with a
new and vibrant menu featuring fresh
pasta
love the menu from 27 dishes down to 15.
why is it reduced because it's fast the
idea is everything's cooked to water
it's fresh chaat grilled calamari with
fresh chili and arugula the main entrees
pisteka fresh caponata with white beans
pasta of the day is going to be
tacotelli of mussels and clams that's
the hallmark paul is that menu
manageable yep looking at the menu and
the bar is set at the 10 and we need to
be able to get as high to the 10 as
possible
certainly nothing less than an eight and
a half
deserves sharon tara cake look at it
beautiful i'm sure sexy and something
you want to take home to bed
oh yeah
what take home to bed oh boy
[Music]
you're killing me
hello welcome you are panera with the
new menu and the new decor in place
follow me please chef ramsay has invited
vips and dignitaries to show why
bizzini's is special even amongst the 60
restaurants in town
let's see what this new menu offers us
all pastas fresh made here on the
premises today i'm going to have the
calamari calamari to search off
excellent
first order yes you have one plenty of
calamari yes yeah yeah one totally yes
chef one taco telly al i would get the
calamari working okay okay one try and
get a little bit more color on it
ticket's coming in i'm not thinking
about am i gonna be able to do it i'm
not thinking about oh my god we're gonna
crash it's about me pushing myself to be
the person that i
am
tonight paul's attitude couldn't be
better get like four more plenties
working please and everything in the
kitchen seems to be right on track this
is table number 21 okay good now the
first appetizers are at the pass
hey guys it's raw here
[Music]
no i can't send out raw calamari yeah
paul please yes it's [ __ ] raw my god
make sure everything's cool
these tables are very important i need a
second to
think you got come on i need help i need
you to get in the game with me please i
can't do it all alone al please tell me
at polenta please tell me how it polenta
i know what's on the line i know we got
taken terry's in a diner we have to get
the job done we have to get it done well
we have to just get it done
and order in that stable 21. guys i
can't cook and talk and manage the
tickets i need help i'm not working
alone here
boom was a total disaster he got
flustered i guess and there was a lack
of communication
the pressure of relaunch night has
clearly gotten to paul his sous chef al
and the rest of the kitchen staff now
we're not firing at the moment and 45
minutes in not a single entree has left
the
kitchen so highly of the fresh pasta
yeah
talk to me paul please okay 24. totally
need special there's only a two top yeah
but chef i want to get this four pastas
out first yeah i know but what i'm
trying to say to you is it's the same
dish put a four and a two top together
kill two birds with one stone position
yourself absolutely manipulate the board
to your advantage come on an hour and a
half later of course we're hungry yeah
this is time
i absolutely understand well i hate to
say it but 33 has been waiting forever
i mean they're one of the first tables
that walks in the store everything is a
complete mess nobody's getting their
food the orders are all mixed up it's
just unbelievable out there these vib
tables yeah are waiting too long i need
some help i need someone to move tickets
i can't do everything myself
communication
we need to [ __ ] cook we're sinking
like the titanic in here
let's just cook
[Music]
this is such a shame paul's shut down
he's not communicating and more
importantly i think he's given up
let's see come on paul
paul i'm doing 400 things at once i'm
trying to do damage control at this
point damage troll is not what i want to
do just what i want to cook i want to
get food out i want you know clearly i
need some help 41.
i need to know how long i need someone
to tell me what 41 is don't have eyes in
the back of my head okay okay what's our
eta on 45 paul
talked out guys
please stop cooking
45. i still don't have an answer i'm 41.
oh okay all right sake this table's been
waiting for an hour can't do it all
right i got this i don't know that's for
sure well i've been waiting for like
this everybody here is waiting hey don't
shush me we're all working together here
we don't need a sister guys
this is the most important night of this
guy's life
quickly arguing
everything crashed i don't know it was a
titanic or the hindenburg but it's a
[ __ ] mess all right i know you don't
want to hear this but i need a pasta
special and i need it immediately buddy
hell where's al where's my sushi the
only one in this kitchen
ow
[Music]
where is al i don't know where the [ __ ]
is out we don't know he's gone no sign
of him he's clearly gone god's sakes man
[Music]
where is he
it's relaunch night at buzzini's and not
only are customers getting restless an
hour and a half later of course we're
hungry but sous chef al has gone awol
where's al where's my sous chef oh
oh i think he quit
i was shocked that al walked out that
really sucks
there was a shock wave that went through
the kitchen the service staff no one
could really
believe it
come on guys please when you just left
high and dry like that it's a little
difficult listen to me al may be gone
but the customers need feeding let's
support one another but as a human being
with compassion you go in you help and
you give it your best shot all right
take a deep breath i'm glad to help if
you cook the garnishes i can cook the
lamb the strip yes yes let's go then i
can only imagine what's happening in
that kitchen back there start working on
three tags two pepper deli straight
after yes yes good i'll do the risotto
sharon are you with me i'm totally with
you shower congratulations to the new
sous chef i'm very embarrassed our sous
chef walked out it's not even paul it's
too tight you know it's like it's like
staunch yeah
good girl sean
thank you chef good girl let's go
talk to me come on paul please i'm one
minute from dressing
i'm one minute from dressing jeff i'm
working it's still gonna be a few
minutes i apologize tag special in the
window thank you sharon service please
to save tonight's dinner service chef
ramsay has taken over the kitchen come
back to the risotto please
and along with sharon's help hold on
sharon food is now entering the dining
room asking each other sometimes in time
received but now the question is
do the customers feel it was worth the
wait
the food is fantastic worth the wait
risotto has a wonderful taste mm-hmm
[Music]
we had some challenges you know we had
some things that weren't expected to
happen but that said everyone stepped up
as best as they could got good feedback
from the people so you know
i feel with success
before i spend some time with paul and
leslie i just want to say a big thank
you yeah your desserts are fantastic
over the desserts your personality is
for me fundamental to the longevity and
the potential success of this restaurant
and i just want to say uh a big thank
you welcome
i enjoyed his company i think he enjoyed
mine and i hope i made him proud thank
you because i really tried very hard
[Music]
right that wasn't easy
no no nowhere near it uh however
i know the customers love the food
absolutely yeah and tonight confirmed
that you have an identity
the fresh pasta
is out there
but
truthfully
as hard as this is for me to say to you
face to face
honestly paul
you haven't changed enough
to convince me
that this
can turn around
[Music]
i
was
totally focused and totally committed no
no no
you weren't poor
jeff no come on big boy the first
appetizer had raw squid
not slightly seared
raw 20 minutes later the place was sunk
you needed me
i regrouped got the kitchen back
together
i've never
worked this hard in launching a
restaurant
the truth hurts paul you've got to start
telling yourself some serious home
truths the way to becoming a better chef
is to realize your weaknesses and
improve those weaknesses
i've taken all of the advice and i've
taken a lot of it to heart and i've seen
a lot of it of what i do is wrong here's
my advice at the heart of this
restaurant has to be you
your food you on the plate
you have to stand up to the plate and
hold the reins i know that it starts and
stops with me and i know that i have to
be the leader and i know that i have to
command the troops and i take
responsibility for it you
say all the right things always but now
it's time to do the right things
rice
can i think
i think that jeff ramsey came in and
really
identified the problems and i think he
certainly helped paul and i totally feel
that all the tools we have are enough to
save the restaurant chef yes chef good
luck thank you very much yes appreciate
everything appreciate all your good work
and and everything you've done for me
it's over to you now
i won't let you down this experience has
been amazing i've been put on the path
to success that i'm really excited about
going forward
please don't let yourself down thanks
very much good night
what a week
ridgewood may have 60 restaurants within
four blocks but i do believe the new
bezini's with its fresh pasta can be a
huge local success
unfortunately i'm just not sure about
paul but
nothing would make me happier if you
could prove me wrong
[Music]
after gordon's departure paul
immediately hired a strong sous chef and
with the new fresh pasta identity
vizzini's experienced a boost in
business
sadly sharon left the restaurant to get
away from paul and to focus on her own
dessert business
[Music]
you